the new star entering the late night
world or in his case not
too late night elmo the monster host
taking time out of his busy schedule to
answer some questions from me
and of course my five-year-old son
macklin
elmo what you like oh hosting your own
self
what's it like oh it's really fun you
almost get to meet lots of different
people
and ask them lots of questions what are
your favorite guests on youtube
um we have the jonas brothers
oh wait i don't like mr jimmy fallon
friends
and today elmo welcomes dad of two jason
sedakis and mom of three sierra on the
season finale of the not too late show
on hbo max i just love visiting your
show elmo
is semi street show up
sesame street is still there yep i
thought that broke down
nothing can stop sesame street go ahead
tell them a joke
why did the bird fly out your house why
because they wanted to eat a cookie
[Applause]
what has two thumbs and is super excited
right now
this guy
i'll send you a card and it would say
elmo you're the best
talk show holster ah thank you so much
and i'm
gonna send a card back to you
but thank you very much it was nice to
meet you